the insurance premiums on that hardest
at this point must be astronomical so no
particular impetus for this I just
wanted to ramble this out of my system
before it becomes relevant again cuz it
will inevitably they keep doing it or at
least new who keeps doing it and that is
blowing up the TARDIS
please stop to stop it's become kind of
traditional a new era Doctor Who the
TARDIS didn't used to blow up all that
much in classic who you know maybe you
get a spark off the panel now and then
but these days holy cow like the whole
thing goes haywire and looks like it's
being devoured from the inside out by
explosions and fire and energy why is
this the norm like I get how it started
and I even get how it escalated a little
but why is it still here so with new
whoo it kind of started it had its soft
start with Tennant or at least that laid
the groundwork because for the most part
the blowing up the TARDIS has been tied
to the regenerations that's how new who
has been doing it
so when Eccleston regenerated into
Tennant know the TARDIS did not blow up
but the next story did open with him
crashing the thing and landing it very
haphazardly bouncing it off buildings
now pretty low-key it's not an explosion
but it
did sort of set up the well if he just
regenerated Betty can't control the
TARDIS thing which honestly in and of
itself that's not an awful idea but then
then came tennis regeneration into Smith
which just blew up the TARDIS from the
inside out with the regeneration energy
which is weird
this is far from the first time he has
regenerated inside the TARDIS and that's
never caused it to blow up before now
it's even been argued before that it's
much safer for him to regenerate inside
the TARDIS than outside of it yet here
it is blowing up now you can try and
justify that narrative Lee any number of
ways you can try and justify it by
saying that he's not just releasing the
energy of a regeneration he's expelling
out the radiation that was killing him
you could argue that the fact that he
kind of had a weird half regeneration
before made this one a little more
potent cuz he had kind of held it back
that it created the the meta doctor and
all of that you could make these
arguments but that's trying to no prise
it because the reason it's there is
because Davies just really really wanted
to go out with a bang it's why the end
of end of time part 2 goes on for as
long it does and we have so many
goodbyes with so many characters and
this big dramatic operatic music and I
don't want to go and yeah boy of the
TARDIS is like a cherry on top of that
slightly self-indulgent cake but okay
end of an era more so than a
regeneration usually is because you know
yes this doctors leaving but also the
showrunners leaving you know okay and
then Smith
in dick Capaldi we get the immediate for
kidding out of pilot the thing and it
goes into us crash again didn't blow it
up this time not to the same degree but
again losing control it just kind of
very haphazardly shows up then we've got
Capaldi into Whitaker not only after a
fairly common itial regeneration moment
and actually that's another thing that's
worth pointing out about the Smith into
Capaldi one it's like he changes like Oh
new body uh
so like it feels very tacked on it's
it's a it's the worst kind of
cliffhanger it's a force-on-force
cliffhanger of like always the turn it's
gonna well no he just regenerated
there's no tension in that we know
they're gonna be fine
and so then with Capaldi and Whitaker
you know she looks at herself she's a oh
all brilliant and then stuff stirs
blowing up why and the turnest appears
to actually dump her out why we've
actually still not gotten the firm
answer on that and I'm not even
necessarily saying I wanted address cuz
I thought it was stupid in the first
place so maybe we'll just move on from
it that's just as well but like if
you're gonna do that freaking have a
reason yeah I've seen them more than a
few people try and justify to me that
the reason that the TARDIS keeps blowing
up is so that they can redesign it but
that doesn't hold up even if I discard
the fact of how many redesigns happen in
the classic era without blowing up the
TARDIS once to the best of my knowledge
I myself have seen all classic so if I'm
wrong about that and they blew it up at
some point somebody will correct me
actually twelve people will correct me
whatever but even if I restricted to
modern era Doctor Who
there was a major redesign of the TARDIS
interior in the middle of Smith's run
from when the pons left to the snowmen
where we first where we got proto Clara
better Clara massive redesign from the
winds of whimsical orange-tinted sort of
multi-layered thing we got the green
tinted sort of more mechanical looking a
little bit less whimsical interior the
TARDIS serious redesigned like from the
ground up and they didn't have to blow
it up before they did it so don't try
and justify to me that they have to blow
up the TARDIS because if they don't they
can't redesign it they can redesign
whenever they want the doctor would just
do that I mean in that case if you want
to justify it he just had massive
upheaval in his life losing the pons and
so he didn't want it to look like the
place that have when they were there
okay fine you want to do that but also
you know what why can't the doctor just
tinker just mess around with it cabal
they did a little bit there are
differences between Smith's
and his even though the fundamental core
construction didn't change the lighting
changed a little bit
we got additions like the chalkboard and
the bookcases and it felt a bit more
like him the doctor can tweak the doctor
can even massively redesign if he wants
again maybe this is just my head Canon
because I like to think of the doctor
sitting around if he's bored doing stuff
like adding functions to the sonic
screwdriver or redesigning the interior
the TARDIS because because he's got a
few hours to kill and he doesn't know
what else to do with himself
he's somebody and I'm like I'm saying he
I'm defaulting to he because most of
these are generations and these
innocence I've talked about at least
started out with a male figure I really
gotten does it need to get into the
habit of going would they get it given
that we're at the point of the doctor be
either male or female depending on when
you're talking about it so I really
should do
they as a collective but I'm still
getting used to that guys cut and then I
say guy folks people language habits
they're annoying so anyways I pictured
the doctor doing this sort of stuff and
maybe that's me being headcanon and what
I like to think and maybe no one else
thinks that the doctor does that but I
do
stop blowing it up there's no tension in
it
there's not even ceremony in it it's
just the last time that it happened it
just happened for absolutely no reason
whatsoever and it was dumb the first
time it happened it was a little dumb
and a kind of overblown but it fit the
mood you know when Tennant regenerating
to Smith it hit the mood of the moment
I'll give you that at least it was kind
of thematic Smith into Capaldi with him
losing control was stupid and
unnecessary cheesy but it was dialed
down a little so that was nice I suppose
but would occur compile the into
whitaker and it just starts exploding it
doesn't even fit thematically stop I
don't know like honest to god I don't
ever want to see the TARDIS blow up
again what actually likes that time to
do this ran fought about it the actual
proper blowing up the TARDIS hasn't
happened that many times but I'm still
super sick of it and I'm sick of the
smaller derivative version of doctor
regenerates and then immediately loses
control and crashes the thing I don't
have a problem with the doctor losing
control of the TARDIS I think the doctor
should be all that good at piling
piloting the TARDIS it's more fun that
way but just this is false tension the
tension is already there auto
regeneration just from us wondering what
will this doctor be like blowing up the
TARDIS doesn't add to that just makes it
dumb so stop
blow up the TARDIS so says me what are
your thoughts on this did I just like go
off on something that nobody else even
cares about slightly ya probably have
been known to do that but whatever your
thoughts are drop so many down the
comments let's talk about it other stuff
to do like subscribe bell go ahead also
I have a patreon it's in the description
and any assistance you would care to
give me even at all or a month it is
quite a big help other lays down there
besides click on stuff the links they
take you places or don't you don't have
to end of the day you're the council
just running the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
why did I say it in that tone I don't
know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]